I'm professor Larry Foulke and I teach courses in nuclear engineering at the University of Pittsburgh.
Nuclear energy is relatively new.
It's based on remarkable scientific discoveries made in the early 20th century.
In this course, I'll introduce you to those discoveries...
...and how they have been translated into a capability to generate electricity.
A global resource that will increase in need as the world population grows...
...to between nine and ten billion people by 2050.
Now in spite of the recent event at Fukushima in Japan,...
...there are over 435 nuclear reactors operating in the world today.
And that population is growing with 62 reactors under construction worldwide.
What exactly is nuclear energy?
What is its history?
Why is it so controversial?
How do nuclear power plants work?
What about nuclear weapons?
What are the stereotypes and misconceptions?
I believe that citizens everywhere need to understand nuclear energy...
...so they can either recognize that it represents an immensely valuable technology...
...or determine it's a threat to the health and safety of the world's population.
Or perhaps the truth lies somewhere in between.